joining us now to roam Corsi who himself
has basing his own legal fight with the
special counsel after rejecting Muller's
plea deal because he says he refuses to
lie under oath against President Trump
dr. Corsi was criminally threatened and
coerced to tell a lie call it the truth
as he explained on this show and now
here to give us further reaction author
of the book silence no more dr. jerome
corsi
you spent 40 hours with Muller correct
yes on 40 hours and they were willing to
sit here 72 years old right
yes I'm 72 and in the course of
answering questions you didn't remember
email specifically from two years prior
correct at times you amended some of
your testimony almost continuously
because as a set of another human tape
recorder you can't punch a button and I
can't remember precisely conversations
or emails in this gotcha game that the
Mueller prosecutors were determined to
play if he came up psychologically
really disturbing and by the end of 40
hours I think my mind was complete mush
I can't tell you who is on the show
Monday so I don't know I mean I've been
with you but when you found out and when
you went through your papers and your
emails and stuff you said oh I got that
wrong here's the truth you amended it
look first your reaction to the pre-dawn
raid of Roger stone today well I was
shocked I mean I think this is
gestapo-like tactics I mean what's the
point in having all these armed police
with riot gear bursting into a house at
7:00 a.m. wife and Roger in bed I mean
this is not America this is not the way
we treat people in America who are
basically trying just to be political
operatives who are earning a living and
I mean it it frightens me to think what
the FBI could do bursting into my home
with my wife asleep and the family
asleep there's no need for it and I
think increasingly that we're seeing an
out-of-control Mueller operation that is
determined to terrorize people and
criminalize politics I think it's very
frightening for the direction of America
you are do you
still fear because when you were fused
to sign what you said was a lie what was
said to you and your attorneys and are
you afraid that they're now going to
pre-dawn raid you in your house well it
could happen I mean the attorneys why
attorneys were told by the Mueller group
well we'll take it from here very angry
arrogant and that's of course now been
the end of November and nothing has
happened I think when I read this
indictment today it's absolutely clear
I'm not being accused of no wrongdoing I
I've done nothing wrong Shawn I brought
it and offered all my computer's my
backup systems my cell phone my emails I
went in to cooperate I've offered to
cooperate throughout the process and
I've I did not willingly and knowingly
give information I knew to be false to
deceive the special prosecutor I had a
memory problems you're referred to as
person number one in Rogers indictment
and they go through a series of emails
that were and communications between the
two of you where basically you know
you're saying Oh what does WikiLeaks
have now after this is after Debbie
wasserman-schultz the first Clinton
email dump which we would never would
have gotten probably if a lot of these
things were better protected that's a
different issue for a different day but
it's mentioned you want to find out you
were working for WorldNetDaily at the
time you wanted to find out like
everyone else in the media what else did
Julian Assange and WikiLeaks have what
was he going to release next and you
were talking about it now I know that
you wrote a dissertation at Harvard did
you not on the Pentagon Papers yes in
fact there's my PhD dissertation in 1972
in the Department of Political Science
it was on the Pentagon Papers case I
mean I'm thinking that was now
forty-seven years ago I mean it was
amazing to me that that's what I focused
on but as a journalist I had a right to
talk with Assange to speak with us on to
publish what Assange had it's just that
I I had no contact with us on the New
York Times published it yes yeah by what
you said to me you never talked to
Julian Assange never and I've never said
neither it's Roger stone if I remember
as far as I know I mean I know Roger can
speak for himself but I know for myself
that I have never spoken with Julian
Assange directly or indirectly so no
contact so comparing the Pentagon Papers
case which you did a dissertation
ironically on and looking at this case
all you and Roger want to know is what
does he have neither one of you were
part of a conspiracy to steal
information from anybody nor did you
steal any information from anybody the
precedents 6:3 Supreme Court decision in
the Pentagon Papers case the u.s.
against the New York Times clearly
states that The Times had a right to
publish information as long as they
didn't steal it and you were requesting
information and trying to find
information like many others in the
media what was coming next correct
you're exactly right Sean we had right
to do this it was every every journalist
and person involved in political
operations and the campaign's Julian
Assange not only dropped 40,000 emails
on debbie Wasserman Schultz in July 22nd
2016 within a day or two he said he had
more emails to come and of course the
speculation was rampant I wanted to know
everybody wanted to know and I passed on
a couple of emails to Ted Malek to say
go see Assange Roger had written those
emails but there's no crime in any of
this this is just no idea why he's
confident you seemed let you seem
confident the last time you were on the
show that you were gonna get a free dawn
raid you feel that it's less likely
today why much less likely I think I
push back I've written this book silent
no more the indictment it suggests
nothing I've done that's wrong I believe
I've done nothing wrong and you know if
it does happen well I mean if it does
happen we'll deal with it but my
family's prepared but it has made my
life my family's life my wife the entire
family in nightmare
and days you can't sleep at you know up
days bad days this is not America I was
done nothing wrong I was a journalist I
went in to the best of my ability with
faulty memory I can be convicted of
having a bad memory but I can't be
conveyed
- they're telling the special counsel or
the FBI something I knew to be false to
deceive them it didn't happen all right
well watch carefully this is scary you
know
if Hillary Clinton can delete 33,000
subpoenaed emails a [ __ ] asset market or
hard drive and bust up devices nothing
happens all these other people I ranking
people we know lied to Congress nothing
happens scary for this country